Nick what is one secret you have never
told anyone and you would love to tell
National Television exactly the question
yes number six Nick what is one secret
you've never told anyone very
specifically directed at me
um
you have a very strong self-care that
you have travel like go-to kit you're
right you always keep that thing on
you're helping you know
um okay I don't think the world knows
the secret I'm not like it's not a
sponsored thing this is literally I'm
about to just drop something that's
important self-care is important and the
sort of
regiment looks something like this
there's a a nice rose water
Mist a little bit of that wake the skin
up uh some under eye gels followed by
some good moisturizer
and an under eye cream
got to take care of yourself
it's important
hi everyone we're the Jonas Brothers and
as you can tell we are spilling the E.T
[Music]
cheers boys who's gonna go first I will
that is delicious tea oh it's very good
how are you both feeling right now about
getting back on the road
feel pretty good feel ready you know I
think when we got to Pennsylvania for
rehearsals it was a tease because it was
we're like that close that much closer
yeah and it felt like summer camp
started but the minute we're uh on our
way
to Yankee Stadium that's when it feels
right
I can't wait I'm excited to put it
simply I cannot wait
what are you excited to show the fans
most with this tour
I just want to show them that we can
play every song on every album
I think that is like insane that we were
able to put this together and that is
still going to be an entertaining
function and it's still entertaining
it's not like yeah it doesn't drag it's
more fast everything has a special
moment we made sure we did a full dress
rehearsal with a live audience
two nights ago I think we finally
realized that we can do this thing and
we we built a really exciting show for
the the people out there that have our
question marks in their brain saying how
are these boys going to do this well we
can and we will we'll see you in Yankees
OG fans for new fans oh yeah even if
you're not a fan we built a fun show all
the way around that's right Kevin Joe
and Nick are performing every single
song from five of their albums during
the tour the guys are playing 91 shows
all over the world kicking it off in New
York this Saturday I know how I prep for
this tour how did you guys prep for the
tour are you ready
I got a haircut
that's good um
I got a haircut since I saw you
yesterday no I'm just like that was part
of this version for the tour in general
uh smart I also exercised
exercise good um I bought
Nick you bought me new luggage I did and
me luggage that was wonderful my
beginning of tour gift yeah your tour
gifts are coming uh it'll be at Yankee
Stadium okay I have yet to buy mine
better be
have to do that pressure's on
um it's a haircut luggage what did I do
I went on vacation right before
rehearsals that was really good that
helped my mind get centered nice we
actually all did we all took yeah a
little time oh okay I went to Italia
never heard of it yes the brothers all
enjoyed a little family time before
hitting the road between the three of
them they've got five daughters plus of
course their wives Priyanka Chopra
Sophie Turner and Danielle Jonas and it
sounds like the whole crew could be
joining them on tour from time to time
how do you guys feel about going on the
tour both being dads now is it a little
bit different anything new uh more
luggage more luggage lots of toys that's
why the gift is the luggage
could be no it's it's an adjustment but
it's incredible yeah and uh excited to
to figure it out it's gonna be amazing
love it uh what's the one thing you
cannot forget to pack for this tour well
guys what's rule number one tour my
therapist
new rule number one
um I don't know we always make sure to
pack neck pillows for God
bring a bathing suit there's like 10
rule number ones I think um XBox now
Xbox is important wow
it's important because there's a lot of
downtime turns out and uh
gotta gotta have a gaming system I'm
gonna go with golf clubs golf clubs are
important for me it would be uh probably
um
insulin yeah that would be important
yeah that's a priority
okay which one of us do you think might
cry when we sing little bird
[Music]
me I'll do it
where
we can't be a part of it we can't
actually know because then that would I
think it'll be more people in the
audience crying than us so in the moment
sometimes you're just thinking about the
technicality of the playing performance
yeah and the singer got no time to cry
cut two yeah opening night cry exactly
being like funny he says that because
look at this
[Music]
you know I recently had an amazing
bucket list moment for myself performing
with Billy Joel on stage in Hyde Park
humble brag but fine who would you like
to perform with that's a part of your
bucket list
you can't say Joe Jonas
wouldn't even make the top five yeah
um I would say luckily
we have thank you luckily we have gun
chance to perform with a lot of our Our
Heroes we have Paul McCartney thank you
if you wonder that was Costello Barack
Obama Barack Obama true I missed
president so I have one on you have one
on me I have one on you correct
um but I would say Elton John would be
pretty cool that would be it round out
that list of Legends absolutely
what is your all-time favorite song to
perform I think I know but I like this
probably Uptown Girl with Billy Joel
okay that's a good answer great answer
Nick
um favorite song to perform of ours I
would say he didn't specify yeah I was
actually moving on to the question but
yeah lovebug is my favorite one to
Performance
[Music]
I really enjoy playing
the first album some of the songs from
the first album like the songs like the
self-titled on Australia nice that just
slap we're gonna play Australia in
Australia for the first time on this
tour whoa it's happening we've gotten to
work with some amazing artists and
producers who is someone you still love
to go studio with still love or would
love to you would still love to get in
the studio oh God John Mayer I feel like
that would be awesome
[Music]
exclusive
probably not you probably I think a
Jonas Brothers Paramore uh collab could
be Fuego Haley shut up
[Applause]
[Music]
Kevin what is something you've always
wanted to ask me if you could have any
topping on an ice cream what would it be
foreign
questions here hard-hitting questions ET
exclusive uh I'd like
to mix in some uh
peanut butter components so like a
Reese's situation
a little bit of the Crunch and the
peanut butter I think it pairs very
nicely with ice cream
so yeah and
cookie dough of course
great answer yeah tea has been spilled
and poured thanks CT thanks CT see you
later bye